good you're finally here
now help me close this would you in
terms of pure explorable space and pure
number of activities Dragon Age
Inquisition is very very big in the
course of 85 hours I finished the story
and performed all number of side quests
if they're huge areas I still haven't
visited tons of Secrets still to be
uncovered and lots of characters I still
barely know approaching a hundred hours
and I know there's so much more I need
more types of potions I need more ways
to upgrade the keep that functions as my
home of operations
I haven't even reached maximum level
there still seem to be so many
adventures out there waiting for me and
I crave being able to take them the game
begins with tragedy you are the right
person at the wrong time escaping with
your life even as countless others have
lost theirs
whether you live by chance or whether
the maker himself has marked you for a
greater purpose isn't yet clear but you
have been marked by a magical sigil on
your hand that closes rifts that now
appear in the skies this makes you both
a target and a messiah figure and the
game hardly shines from the implications
you can tailor your Inquisitor in all
sorts of wonderful ways using the game's
intricate character creation system you
then become the Inquisitor you want to
be through dialogue choices and forking
gameplay options you sit upon your
throne and cast judgment on those that
wronged you and then deal with the
repercussions when certain people in
factions don't like your choices and
sometimes you must decide who lives and
who dies who is an enemy and who is a
friend and who leads an entire kingdom
and you will care because the people
surrounding you are so very real so
present there are returning
personalities like Liliana and Hawke and
should you carry over a save they will
recall choices you made in previous
Dragon Age games you'll probably grow to
love some of these party members as well
as the other company you keep Varrick
and his harried dwarf chest return but
as you spend more time with him his
mercenary facade gives way to something
approaching no bill
The Seeker Cassandra who once
interrogated Varrick and who will never
be allowed to forget it is also at your
side both soft and stubborn always
lawful always intent on doing the right
thing their banter is sometimes playful
sometimes tense sometimes mysterious and
sometimes heartbreaking there's a lot of
dialogue that every line is written and
spoken with purpose you meet with some
of these folks at the war table where
you can send agents to perform the
Inquisition's work while you concern
yourself with other matters spreading
your influence and gaining power as
important as power as the currency you
use essentially to buy access to new
quests and areas Dragon Age Inquisition
is not one large unbroken land in the
manner of an Elder Scrolls game but
rather lots of different semi large
attractive lands accessible through your
map and so off you go with your party
traversing areas both green and stormy
you Kollek and war-torn there are herbs
and resources to collect out there which
you use to craft armor weapons and
upgrades when you return to your keep
there are rifts in the sky to close
constellations to gaze at and understand
via a connect-the-dot minigame and
shards to collect those collectables
aren't just busywork though there are
new places and secrets to unveil
exploration has its occasional quirks
some sound bugs some clumsy jumping
puzzles characters occasionally popping
into view and what have you but these
foibles don't really amount to much the
combat is likely to be Dragon aging
positions most divisive feature it's fun
and colorful and if you bolon with the
loss of the tactical camera in Dragon
Age 2 not only is it back but it's back
even on consoles on one hand the
tactical camera can be kind of awkward
here sticking a little too close to
things on the other the ability to use a
single button to forward time instead of
constantly pausing and unpausing is a
great week but unless you're fighting
dragons bosses or venturing into rougher
territory you probably won't need the
tactical camera very often should you
play on medium difficulty most healing
magic is gone so you rely on health
potions that we
clinician camps and towns ultimately
it's a good combat system that works
well in both wide open spaces and
cramped caves and it's certainly the
most fluid of the Dragon Age games when
you play from the usual third-person
view there are challenges out there but
nail-biting battles aren't common hard
mode is always there if you want one
however and there's no doubting the
diversity of gameplay there's a lot more
to Dragon Age Inquisition of course
there's the keep customization which
lets you tailor your headquarters to
your liking there's the cooperative
multiplayer mode a light but enjoyable
horde type mode with enough unlockables
to keep you interested for a while quite
a bit like Mass Effect 3 in that regard
there are cool nooks and crannies at
every turn and robust crafting and
involved reading that can keep you busy
when you aren't out squabbling with
apostates and partying with your Legion
Nobles Dragon Age Inquisition is fun and
surprising and it's horrific melding of
combat storytelling and exploration
[Music]
you